shroud left which for mixer this is
insane all right so before we get into
the news this episode is brought to you
by a video g-force the fact of the
matter is whether you're trying to
compete at the highest level or just
trying to be your friends frames are
what are gonna win you games and these
guys at Nvidia they have the hardware
you need to unlock your full game mates
attention you want to find out more
check out our links in the description
below now that's the shroud alright so
you remember when ninja left which to
stream exclusively on mixer Steve Steve
well I left the country for like two
days and now shrouds gone - when this
happened with ninja everyone couldn't
stop talking about her on Twitter and
there were like 10 million dollar-a-year
numbers being thrown around analysts
we're calling it a huge day for eSports
and millions of 12 year-old kids around
the world we're trying to figure out
what a mixer is well it turns out on
that day a chain-reaction star and guess
who saw this coming
literally everybody over the last two
years shroud has been maybe the only
other streamer comparable the ninja at
the top of twitch and now they're both
gone
honestly I still can't believe it
I figured when this all started we would
see some follow up signings maybe some
smaller guys but shroud and to say this
announcement blew up would be an
understatement
there was supporting droves from the
streaming community on Twitch and the
FPS community at large
and of course ninja with maybe the most
public relations tweet in the history of
Twitter but then of course like anything
that has to do with streaming you had
the haters the og twitch heads that
think crowd somehow selling out and well
instead of making fun of them myself I'm
gonna let dr. Lupo do it for me imagine
getting mad at someone for for them
making more money so much just so just
you don't ya you guys realize shrouds
bed is probably made out of $100 bills
now right yeah
do you guys it was before this it was
also before but it is now ya know it's
Louie Vuitton gold and plate yeah
alright so now we're here shroud and
ninja have exclusive multi-year
screaming deals with mixer and the
stream world feels constantly in flux
let's break this down a little further
ninjas deal with mixer started at the
beginning of August and that got the
ball rolling and obviously the next
question is who's next
well actually it was twitch who stepped
up saw all this change happening and
decided to sign NIC mercs to an
exclusive streaming deal which to me was
actually huge almost as big as the mixer
deal in the first place
cuz it showed that twitch they were
willing to step up and offer the kind of
guaranteed money to keep their big stars
streaming where they are look I know
that I keep saying this but it's true
the biggest deal about these moves is
these guys are now being offered direct
money in order to keep streaming on
their channel so instead of being paid
by their subs and donations and maybe
some sponsorships they're being paid
contracts like athletes celebrities or
actors because as we know these guys are
just that famous and so here we are
shroud - mixer and on the same day as
the new Call of Duty drop nonetheless
and to say his fans were stoked is a
huge understatement during the hours
leading up to his debut stream mixer
this countdown on his channel and there
were like 20,000 people watching this
number tick down and as you'd expect
when things finally got up and running
at night it was everything you'd expect
from Trev
it feels so good I tune in for as much
of the night as possible before I
finally passed out with the stream on
but at times there were like 90,000
people in the channel people were
literally going to nothing's twitch at
to find out where shroud was we're shot
$25 just to me this actually might be a
bigger smarter thing for mixer than
getting ninja don't get me wrong
ninja definitely paved the way but
Shroud is as old-school twitch as it
gets and he's bringing a lot more
credibility with him from that old
twitch audience and now that these two
massive streamers are gone I think we
can call this a trend and we don't know
this for sure but you have to imagine
that twitch probably tried to keep
shroud around which means mixer through
so much money item that it didn't matter
or twitch just didn't fight that hard
it's worth noting that shrouds receiving
the same treatment on mixer that ninja
got all the subs are free for the first
month so if these deals are really the
multi-year multi-million dollar
contracts that the rumors suggest then
what's stopping someone like Tim the tat
man or tee foo from making the jump on
board with mixer as well
who's next doctor I was the first one
there and Washington before this guy
before shroud they wanted the number one
I said
Rob like I've said in the past this
company is literally owned by Microsoft
what's a couple million dollars in their
marketing budget if I'm twitch right now
I gotta start signing some of these big
names I'll also say from my personal
experience that watching streams on
mixers kind of sick they offer this much
higher level of video quality than
twitch does which I thought I would
never care about until I started
watching shraddh click heads and Cod
last night now
obviously I can't tell you who's next to
go but man if T foo or even some major
eSport decide to jump ship and stream on
mixer exclusively we'll be here to fill
you in special thanks to Nvidia for
helping us put this video together if
you're looking for more info on them
make sure to hit the link in the
description below shroud Leftwich for
mixer this is insane
all right so before we get into the news